sommes devant tableau des 1000 bernard
qui est un peintre
européen et qui est intitulé qui a pour
titre maison au fond d'un parc et qui
n'étaient pas en 1888 donc ce tableau
est une des grandes toiles majeures du
musée léon dierx puisqu'elle appartient
à une école de peinture enfin courants
de la peinture en france au xviiie qui
s'appelle l'école de pont-aven puisque
emile bernard et d'autres peintres comme
gauguin comme
sérusier comme aussi également van gogh
vont aller en bretagne dans ces années
1880 pour aller trouver autre chose
rompre avec la tradition académique
française rompre avec cette tradition de
la peinture qu'il ait pesé emile bernard
est un rebelle des mines bernard est
quelqu un outil qui n'acceptent pas
l'enseignement de l'école des beaux-arts
et il quitte tout ça et il va aller en
bretagne chez les exotiques breton entre
guillemets pour essayer de puiser dans
ces paysages puiser dans ses traditions
bretonnes puiser dans ses us et coutumes
bretonne en fait une nouvelle trouver
une nouvelle source d'inspiration
trouver une nouvelle façon de peindre en
fait que finalement bernard et gauguin
avons inventé et qu'on va appeler le
croiser au nice alors c'est cette toile
n'est pas encore tout à fait une toile
foisonnent east c'est à dire le creusot
nice mais c'est le fait de ne pas
mélanger les couleurs et de poser les
couleurs les unes à côté des autres et
de les cerner en fait par un trait noir
mais par contre on voit que on est au
début de ce qui se passait déjà qu'on
santé ici on a le dessin préparatoire
soit ce tableau est très présent on voit
le dessin de l'art on voit le dessin de
la maison on sent la volonté de
structurer le premier plan
par 7 ces deux traits noirs par ce
chemin et surtout on voit très bien
qu'ici même si cette peinture est ici de
nuancer on a des touches d'orange en une
touche de fer en est tout jeune mais
l'ombre portée de l'arbre en fait et
très bien délimité par une tâche de vert
foncé de même que le toit de la maison
de même que le ciel de même que le le
nuage au-dessus bref c'est si on est au
début de quelque chose qui va
révolutionner complètement la peinture
puisque se cloisonne isme inventé dans
cette fin 2008 sans être des années 1680
du côté de pont-aven va influencer un
groupe d'un autre groupe d'artistes qui
s'appelle les nabis à la fin du 19e
siècle bref c'est quelque chose c'est
une nouvelle façon de peindre qui après
la révolution des impressionnistes
l'arrivée de claudio nice va
révolutionner complètement la peinture
au à partir de la fin du xixème siècle
mais ce qui est d'autant plus
intéressant aussi c'est que ce tableau
ici dès aujourd'hui au musée léon dierx
c'est grâce en fait à un
personnage extrêmement important dans
l'histoire du musée qui embrase voilà
puisque ambroise vollard qui est un
réunionnais qui était un marchand d'art
qui a découvert carreaux découvert
cézanne qui a exposé pour la première
fois picasso hockey exposer les nabis
les forêts s'est arrêtée à sa mort son
frère lucien vollard donne au musée 153
numéro et sept toiles majeures puisque
c'est vraiment à un des grands
chefs-d'oeuvre du musée le monde hélas
est arrivé à la réunion en 1947 et
permet au musée léon dierx d'évoquer
cette école de pont-aven aux côtés de
masques de picasso au côté d'un tableau
de maximo fera avec quelques pièces
d'évoquer ce grand courant artistique
qui a marqué la peinture française à
partir de la fin du 19e siècle